oh hi hey I'm Andy Beckerman and I'm
Chris there and we're craft services
people for the PETA home show that is
not true right annoys we got over a
hundred thousand responses to our meet
Pete call to arms we got less than 20
submissions somewhere in between and now
we'd like to show you some of our
favorites roll it Tony be home Pete
Holmes Pete Holmes he holmes who is Pete
Holmes Pete Holmes is a luscious man
it's very tall very white aggressively
positive a Batman a he's sort of a
humanoid version of baby Healy hate my
sandwich I'll give him a hand that Pete
Holmes was pretty better heat homes is
like the Jolly Green Giant if he was a
suburban 34 year old from New England
itõs a smart guy I think he went to
Bible College yeah and i think that was
he broke his brain Gordon College
Massachusetts where my darling Pete home
studied Pete Holmes is the type of guy
that will um give you a 20 second hug
even after you like stalked him at his
own stand-up show because you're drunk
and you're in love with him Pete isn't
afraid to make weird for all those
weirdos out there including myself I
appreciate that you're gonna love Pete
he's gonna be like your new friend like
a mug of hot cocoa after tobogganing
like um if a warm hug ever was like hey
Q is weird is weird Oh funny honest yes
mmm drink him in
you